Ludwig van Beethoven's Sixth Symphony is
known as the pastoral and now this
masterpiece is at the center of an
ambitious global project the composer
intended it as an homage to rural life
and nature
the person with the postural Beethoven
composed the word that was particularly
about the relationship between man and
nature with an eye towards this piece of
music we want to focus attention on our
own relationship with nature which of
course today is conditioned by
Environmental Protection and climate
change
the Beethoven pastoral project connects
the Masters music with 21st century
environmental conservation it was
unveiled at the UN climate change
conference Cup 23 in Beethoven's
birthplace Bonn Germany in principle the
pastoral project addresses musicians in
all genres a publicity clip presents
various musicians as project ambassadors
I mean I always like the stories about
Beethoven he would be seen walking in
nature communing with his music but also
with the birds and ourselves what you
hear the idea of transferring the
postural to another world stylistically
interested me right away as did the
project connected with it
I found combining the pastoral nature
and the climate conference very
intriguing
[Music]
jazz violinist Gregor Huebner was one of
the musicians on hand in buns Beethoven
house he presented some of his own
improvisations on the pastoral
a pasta Valley is really the pastoral is
difficult because Beethoven is so good
at developing motifs he can spin a
single motif into a whole symphony the
project ambassadors in this promotional
clip show how it's done
whether rehearsal or performance and
regardless of the instrument what counts
is the final product a unique
interpretation of Beethoven's Pastoral
Symphony
[Music]
the apostolate talk Austral day will be
the high point and the culmination of
the project it will come inside with the
UN World Environment Day on June the 5th
2020 and it will feature as many
variations on the pastoral as possible
played across the globe there are still
two and a half years to go until that
date in the meantime we want to
establish a pastoral network connecting
artists all over the world part of the
Beethoven pastoral project and the BT HV
and 2020 stand up for the preservation
of nature with your pastoral music
starting on June 5th 2018 the next World
Environment Day musicians from all over
the world can present their ideas on the
Internet of how to combine Beethoven's
timeless music with a modern love of
nature
[Music]
you